acoso Morales sexual uso
desproporcionado de la fuerza contra las
personas negras exceso de vigilancia y
poca protección a la población la
policía Metropolitana de Londres está
plagada de racismo institucional sexismo
y homofobia Estas son las palabras de un
informe condenatorio de una importante
investigación independiente se mire como
se mire se llame como se llame se
describa como se describa está
absolutamente Claro que como institución
la policía metropolitana tiene
prejuicios y es discriminatoria
la investigación fue encargada en 2021
tras la condenada de un agente por
violación y asesinato de Sara Ever Art
un caso que conmocionó a la sociedad
británica la crisis de confianza en la
policía londinense se agravó aún más
cuando en enero de este año el agente
David Se declaró culpable de múltiples
agresiones sexuales y 24 violaciones
come tidas entre 2003 y 2020 el jefe de
La Metropolitana reconoce ahora
públicamente el fracaso de su
institución no
se trata solo del horrible hecho de que
tengamos racistas misóginos y homófobos
dentro de la organización
braxley en realidad se trata también de
fallo sistémicos de gestión fallos
culturales
el informe que apunta a una cultura de
negación en la policía pide una reforma
en profundidad con entre otras
recomendaciones una dirección firme un
servicio de Protección de la mujer y una
nueva estrategia para la infancia